[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen alles wichtige vom
sport hat norbert lehmann für sie schon
gut
unsere großen themen in dieser sendung
schlagabtausch der kleineren parteien
csu auf die fdp und die linke liefern
eine hitzige tv-debatte vor der
bundestagswahl
corona infektionen bei den kleinsten
immer mehr kitas setzen auf lolli tests
um ansteckungen zu erfassen
und weltweit einzigartig in frankfurt am
main eröffnet das deutsche romantik
museum nach fast zehn jahren planung
der bundestagswahlkampf ist auf der
zielgeraden und der ton wird zunehmend
rauer viele wählerinnen und wähler sind
noch unentschlossen wem sie ihr kreuz
machen sollen wofür stehen die parteien
darum ging es auch gestern bei einer
weiteren fernsehdebatte csu fw und fdp
und die linke das sind die vier
sogenannten kleinen die beim trial ums
kanzleramt außen vor blieben als
mögliche mehrheitsbeschafferin könnten
die fdp oder die linke aber vielleicht
bald eine schlüsselrolle zu spielen beim
schlagabtausch der vier parteien vor
einem millionen publikum ging es zur
sache der wahlkampf spitzt sich zu ines
trams
diskussion mit jugendlichen
spd-kanzlerkandidat olaf scholz in
potsdam erneut schließt er eine
koalition mit der linkspartei nicht aus
obwohl zuvor die linken-chefin kein
bekenntnis zur nato abgelegt sondern
deren auf lösungen gefordert hatte
stattdessen wirkt scholz für sich
der nächste regierungschef in
deutschland werden kann viele wissen die
zweitstimme für die spd führt dazu dass
der nächste kanzler werden kann und umso
stärker das votum ausfällt umso
einfacher wird es andere geben
am abend hatten sich die sogenannten
kleinen parteien in ard und zdf einen
vierkampf geliefert ohne sie gibt es
womöglich keine neue regierung sie
könnten königsmacher sein die positionen
oftmals unvereinbare zum beispiel beim
thema corona was mich wirklich gekümmert
vertretern dieser runde wird die so tun
als gäbe es corona gar nicht als gäbe es
keine pandemie als wäre es die ganz
normale grippe wir wissen dass es eben
nicht der fall die gesamte locker und
politik ist völlig überzogen schadet der
wirtschaft schade und sein
arbeitsplätzen schadet uns auch
gesellschaftspolitisch streit auch um
die klimawende csu und fdp wollen die
mit technischer innovation erreichen die
linke mit einem vorgezogenen
kohleausstieg die fdp warnt vor der
windkraft heftig der schlagabtausch beim
thema vermögenssteuer sie müssen
vielleicht ein bisschen wirtschaftlicher
ist ein dynamischer prozess
90 milliarden steuerentlastung das steht
ja bei ihrer gramm ist das ist ja
sparsam noch ist das in irgendeiner form
seriös dass es wirklich finanzpolitisch
motto was jemand machen und deswegen
muss ich mir glaube ich von ihnen
ist jürgen fuchs in belehrungen gebe
mich erinnern nur an die mövenpick
steuer und anderes also fürs eigene
klientel also wenn sich auch wenn sie ja
nun nicht und sie soviel von wirtschaft
verstehen würden wer die ddr
untergegangen wie auch olaf scholz zeigt
sich die grüne spitzenkandidatin am tag
danach nicht überzeugt von rot rot grün
sie setzt auf eine koalition mit der spd
[Applaus]
am älterwerden wer will und wer kann mit
wem in rund einer stunde stellt sich
kandidat scholz im zdf den fragen von
bürgern
also um 20.15 heißt es bei uns klartext
herr scholz alles wichtige zur
bundestagswahl haben wir für sie
gebündelt auf zdf heute und in unserer
app inklusive faktenchecks
die staatsanwaltschaft osnabrück hat ein
ermittlungsverfahren gegen den
staatssekretär im
bundesfinanzministerium wolfgang schmidt
eingeleitet im zusammenhang mit razzien
im finanzministerium soll ich mit den
durchsuchungsbeschluss rechtswidrig in
teilen bei twitter veröffentlicht haben
sagte die staatsanwaltschaft bei dem
einsatz ging es um ermittlungen gegen
verantwortliche einer geldwäsche
spezialeinheit des zolls und wir blicken
auf die pandemie kinder unter zwölf
jahren sind bisher nicht geimpft sie
erkranken seltener schwer aber
mittlerweile infizieren sie sich immer
häufiger die inzidenz bei kindern
beträgt bei den bis vierjährigen aktuell
85 bei über 5 jährigen gar
186 wegen infektionen oder
verdachtsfälle mussten auch in diesem
jahr immer wieder kitas schließen und
kitagruppen in quarantäne hier
bundesweite stichprobe bis ende august
allein in berlin waren vergangene woche
23 kindertagesstätten teils oder
komplett geschlossen damit es nicht mehr
werden soll nun lolli tests helfen lisa
ja die hat sich angeschaut wie das
funktioniert und auf
läuft 30 sekunden lutschen für den lolli
test zweimal die woche und viel
angenehmer als der nasenabstrich
das stäbchen ist eigentlich
geschmacksneutral aber mit ein bisschen
fantasie
[Musik]
insgesamt 30 berliner kitas machen bei
dem pilotprojekt mit alle tupfer in ein
rohr ab ins labor ergebnis noch am
selben tag an der uniklinik köln wurde
das lolli verfahren entwickelt nur wenn
ein sammel test positiv ist gibt es nach
tests um zu prüfen wer infiziert ist das
besondere es handelt sich um pcr-test
die sind sehr genau und können die
infektion schon erkennen bevor sich
andere anstecken es ist glücklicherweise
so dass kinder in aller regel nicht
schwer erkranken und kleine kinder für
die gilt das besonders aber es ist
dennoch so auch wenn es sehr selten ist
wenn sie halt sehr sehr viele
infektionen haben dann sehen sie eben
doch dann auch gehäuft solche schweren
verläufe und das wollen wir natürlich
verhindern berlin abrupt noch in köln
gibt es die lolli test schon an allen
kitas die bundesärztekammer fordert
einen flächendeckenden einsatz in kitas
und schulen bundesweit
weil sie für kinder gut durchführbar und
zumutbar sind auf der einen seite und
auf der anderen seite das maximum an
sensitivität empfindlichkeit haben so
dass wir tatsächlich so viele
infektionen wie möglich auf diese weise
herausfischen können für die kinder der
kita kleiner fratz gibt es zur belohnung
einen echten lolli diesmal wirklich mit
geschmack
damit wir jetzt auf die aktuellen zahlen
zu corona das robert koch institut
meldet
6325 neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 401 weniger als am
vergangenen dienstag 68 menschen starben
im zusammenhang mit kobe 19 binnen eines
tages die sieben tage incident sinkt
leicht auf
81,15
132 weitere krone infizierte kam ins
krankenhaus damit steigt die
hospitalisierung rate auf 1,86
generelle auffrischimpfung gegen korona
ja oder nein nein sagen hochrangige
expertinnen der
weltgesundheitsorganisation sowie der
us-arzneimittelbehörde
solange viele ärmere länder noch auf
erste impfdosen warten würden gebe es
keine notwendigkeit vollständig
geimpften in reicheren ländern eine so
genannte booster impfung anzubieten
im fachmagazin the lancet verweisen sie
auf entsprechende studien
großbritanniens premier johnson setzt
dagegen auf die auffrischimpfungen in
london stellte er seine pläne für die
nächsten monate vor für etwa 30
millionen menschen wird bereits ab
nächster woche eine dritte impfung
angeboten als verschärfende maßnahme
könnte bei steigenden zahlen die masken
pflicht wieder eingeführt werden sowie
impfpässe für discos oder stadien im
juni hatte man fast alle corona
beschränkungen aufgehoben
er ist der erste deutsche bischof dem
selbst sexualisierte gewalt gegen kinder
vorgeworfen wird die amtszeit des lange
verstorbenen bischof janssen im
katholischen bistum hildesheim wurde
daher untersucht und das gutachten heute
veröffentlicht es zeigt fälle
sexualisierter gewalt seien über einen
langen zeitraum gezielt verschwiegen
oder vertuscht worden und wird deutscher
berichtet
71 tatverdächtige 45-jähriger und 26
weltliche mitarbeiter überwiegend männer
sie stehen laut unabhängiger studien im
zusammenhang mit sexualisierter gewalt
an kindern und jugendlichen der seit
drei jahren amtierende hildesheimer
bischof rainer wilmer hatte die studie
2009 sind in auftrag gegeben das
ergebnis ist für mich schockierend
es ist für mich entsetzlich zu sehen
weder schutz der institution der kirche
über allem stand wie der schutz von
priestern die zu tätern von
gewaltverbrechen wurden auch über allem
stand und wie betroffene menschen
überhaupt nicht vorkam untersucht wurde
der zeitraum von 1957 bis 82 die
amtszeit des hildesheimer bischofs
heinrich maria jansen das ergebnis ging
anschuldigung sexualisierter gewalt
nicht nach vertuschte konsequenzen für
die tatverdächtigen gab es nicht und der
1988 verstorbene jansen ist der erste
deutsche bischof dem selbst sexueller
missbrauch vorgeworfen wird bischof
janssen wird beschuldigt
haben keine anhaltspunkte dafür dass das
was die zeugen vorgetragen haben falsch
gut dass endlich untersucht wurde sagt
jens findel selbst missbrauchsopfer er
hätte sich aber mehr erwartet ich habe
mir gewünscht dass der prüfauftrag etwas
weitergegangen wäre dass man umfassender
berichtet hätte können täter namen
genannt hätte
das wäre für mich offener und
transparenter gewesen bischof wilma
kündigte an weiteren vorwürfen
sexualisierter gewalt nachzugehen der
bereich prävention soll im bistum
hildesheim personell aufgestockt werden
pabst franziskus hat ein zeichen gegen
ausgrenzung gesetzt weil seine reise die
slowakei besuchte er auch eines der
größten roma viertel europas in der
plattenbausiedlung von kosice bat der
papst um vergebung an diskriminierungen
und misshandlungen von roma seien auch
katholiken nicht unbeteiligt er
verurteilte die diffamierung von
minderheiten um war für integration und
ein gegenseitiges kennenlernen in kosice
leben tausende roma unter zum teil
erbärmlichen bedingungen
norwegen steht vor einem
regierungswechsel bei der parlamentswahl
wurde die konservative regierung von
ministerpräsidentin soll bergab gewählt
sie räumte die niederlage bereits ein
neuer regierungschef wird
voraussichtlich der sozialdemokrat und
ehemalige außenminister störe der
wahlkampf war von der klimakrise und der
zukunft der öl und gasindustrie in
norwegen bestimmt
heute ist der weltweite tag der
tropenwälder und da werfen wir einen
blick nach brasilien denn dort wurde im
vergangenen jahr auch durch brandrodung
eine fläche regenwald zerstört die
größer ist als thüringen und das hat
langfristige folgen denn die tropischen
regenwälder sind nicht nur effektive co2
speicher sie sind rund um den globus
natürliche klimaanlage
sie verdunsten viel wasser das kühlt und
sorgte atmosphäre dafür dass die
feuchtigkeit zirkuliert und sich als
regen auch weit über den wald hinaus
verteilt ein global wichtiger kühl und
feuchtigkeit kreislauf viele initiativen
kämpfen deshalb in brasilien um die
regenwälder einmal abgeholzt kommen
diese nur durch gezielte aufforstung
wieder christoph haker rat hat das
institut terra besucht
die urwaldriesen von morgen sind noch
winzig gärtner und muss sehr vorsichtig
sein beim umsetzen ins nächste beet
sie sind wie kleine kinder sie werden
erst geboren dann wachsen sie hier ein
wenig und kommen dann sozusagen ins
kinder wenn
diese kinderbettchen stehen zu tausenden
im gewächshaus im institut era einem
beispielhaften aufforstungsprojekt im
südosten brasiliens
leiterin isabellas auto erklärt die
komplexe wissenschaft dahinter
wir müssen in diesem prozess mit den
pflanzen beginnt die wir pioniere nennen
die schnell wachsen eine wald struktur
aufbauen um diese dann mit den anderen
arten anzureichern
vw zahlt sie noch ist
ein baum wird der 20 meter hoch ist aber
der überhaupt keine chance hat wenn man
nämlich vorher hier in dieser anlage
hier erstmal aufpäppelt denn von selbst
kommt einmal abgeholzter regenwald nicht
zurück er muss aktiv gepflanzt werden
mit genau der richtigen mischung
unterschiedlicher arten die samen der
bäume werden im eigenen labor erforscht
wo einst kahlschlag war grünt es wieder
doch insgesamt nimmt die abholzung in
brasilien weiter zu beklagt der gründer
des instituts der berühmte fotograf
sebastian zagato
die aktuelle regierung ist absolut
unverantwortlich die aktuelle regierung
muss bestraft werden wirtschaftlich und
politisch
um den regenwald zu retten braucht es
den politischen willen wissenschaft und
harte arbeit baum für baum sonst bleibt
der wald verloren
zurück nach deutschland das archiv zur
erforschung der geschichte der juden hat
ein neues zuhause bekommen mit einem
festakt in heidelberg in den mauern
einer ehemaligen tabakfabrik sind nun
die zeugnisse jüdischen gemeindelebens
in deutschland nach 45 zentralverein
dokumente nachlässe und aufzeichnungen
jüdische bürgerinnen
das archiv wurde 1987 gegründet und war
bisher in verschiedenen außenstellen
untergebracht
und nun wird's romantisch wobei er
sofort die frage aufkommt was genau ist
romantik
kulturgeschichtlich ist es eine woche
vom ende des 18 jahrhunderts bis weit
ins 19 jahrhundert der geist dieser zeit
spiegelt sich besonders eindrucksvoll in
den werken des malers caspar david
friedrich wieder aber die romantik
umfasst auch literatur musik ist eine
geisteshaltung was genau ihr kern ist
damit befasst sich das weltweit erste
romantik museum in frankfurt am main
peter theisen mit eindrücken
keine romantik ohne ihn
vater rhein mit seinen burgen der strom
der die deutschen dichter inspirierte
und auch die maler entdeckten in ruinen
und zauberhaften landschaften ihre
romantische motive als reaktion auf
moderne und aufklärung
dann haben wir da eine zeit in der der
verstand als wesentliches instrument und
fähigkeit des menschen in den
mittelpunkt gestellt wird und die
romantiker reagieren dann darauf und
sagen der mensch hat aber auch andere
fähigkeiten sinnlichkeit fantasie
einbildungskraft gefühl im museum lassen
sich die lebens und schaffens wege der
romantiker miteinander verknüpfen von
caspar david friedrich bis zu joseph von
eichendorff dessen gedicht wünschelrute
ist im original zu sehen und wieder
dichter ringen musste bis die
romantischen zeilen schließlich perfekt
waren es ist wirklich romantisch es ist
in modernen gemäuern romantisch geworden
allein durch die beleuchtung allein wenn
sie die treppe hochgehen und diese
himmelstreppe bekommen sie schon eine
bestimmte stimmung vermittelt und das
ist ja doch eine sehr romantische
technik
romantische gefühle erzeugt auch eine
nische in sehnsuchts blau das museum ein
auto fühlen und lernen gleichermaßen die
botschaft der romantik ist utopien
wieder zuzulassen in die zukunft zu
denken und die fantasie zu aktivieren
und damit ein mächtiges instrument zu
haben mit dem man die realität verändern
kann und ich glaube genau das brauchen
wir wer die botschaften der romantik
sehen und hören möchte der hat in
frankfurt nun die chance dazu
[Musik]
einige haben ja auch bei fußball fast
romantische gefühle also kommt jetzt
champions league das wir heute zwei
deutschen eine bayern tritt in barcelona
an und der post die wolfsburger die
müssen nach will der vfl momentan ja in
topform tabellenführer in der bundesliga
der französische meister dagegen ist nur
mittelmäßig in die neue saison gestartet
mark von bommel setzt auf
siegermentalität beim vfl wolfsburg so
war er als spieler so ist er als trainer
egal ob man spieler oder trainer kempf
pflege ist das größte auf preisniveau
ist ein kleiner sache die das spiel
entscheiden und nikolaus der für das
frische spielgewinn van bommel als
spieler 2006 champions league sieger mit
dem fc barcelona derzeit auch als
trainer auf einem höhenflug mit dem
perfekten bundesliga start für wolfsburg
vier spiele vier siege tabellenführer
jetzt geht es gegen den französischen
meister osc lille nach fünf spieltagen
ist der nur zwölfter in der liga den
letzten auftritt in der champions league
hatten die wolfsburger 2016 damals
scheiterte der vfl knapp im
viertelfinale an real madrid jetzt die
rückkehr in die königsklasse mit der
siegermentalität alles mark van bommel
morgen spielt der bvb in istanbul gegen
besiktas eine lösbare aufgabe leipzig
dagegen muss beim englischen meister
manchester city run nach dem schlechten
start in der bundesliga folgt für rb
gleich der erste große härtetest in der
königsklasse die ausgabe der flugscheine
bei rasenball leipzig noch ganz analog
beherzt freudiger zugriff vor der
dienstreise nach england trainer jesse
marsch muss seiner mannschaft nach dem
fehlstart in der bundesliga die freude
am spiel vermitteln dass 1 zu 4 gegen
bayern vom vergangenen wochenende nicht
selbstbewusstsein fördern meister
manchester city und pep guardiola
favoriten in der gruppe mit paris st
germain in der abgelaufenen champions
league saison im finale dem fc chelsea
unterlegen aber wieder heißer kandidat
auf den gewinn des henkel ein perfekt
eingespieltes team gegen leipziger die
sich erst wieder finden müssen vor allem
gestärkte offensivkraft wird nötig sein
um gegen den übermächtig wirkenden
gegner bestehen zu können
ja und alle deutschen spiele und alle
highlights ab morgen im champions league
sportstudio mittwochs 23 uhr bei uns im
zdf
und drin bleiben und fernsehen passt gut
denn das wetter wird ungemütlich mit
schauern und gewittern alles weitere
dazu erfahren sie gleich von ist intelli
das heute journal mit marietta slomka
können sie um 21 45 sehen machen das gut
[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zum wetter das
langsam ziele tief über england das
wandert allmählich nach nordosten
richtung skandinavien und bringt schauer
und gewitter heute gab es schon im
westen gewitter ja und dabei wird auch
noch die warme luft abgedrängt also es
wird nicht mehr ganz so warm werden in
den nächsten tagen schauen wir in die
nacht star gibt es schauer und gewitter
über nacht im westen und gewitter auch
im südwesten
ansonsten ist es nach osten hin trocken
mit temperaturen von bis zu zehn grad
dort relativ kühl deutlich milder im
rhein main gebiet mit 19 grad morgen
tagesverlauf sehr durchwachsenes wetter
einmal quer über deutschland schauer und
gewitter die durchziehen am ehesten noch
nach osten und im südosten deutschlands
trockene abschnitte mit temperaturen bis
26 grad dort wo die sonne scheint und 20
grad ganz im westen deutschlands am
kühlsten wird es in schleswig holstein
mit 18 grad sein schauen wir auf die
nächsten tage am donnerstag vor allem im
osten dicht bewölkt und im süden mit
schauern gewittern bis 22 grad ab
freitag wird es etwas ruhiger nur noch
wenige schauer und samstag komplett
trocken damit ein schöner abend